[Applause]
trouble calls out now they switched
holidays defense Vincent in and out
Jonas has it
get it to Middleton two-point game
bubbles steps in front Middleton
Allen has it down the lane he's one out
of time the Bucks don't get off the shot
and the Miami Heat become the sixth in
NBA history to win as an eighth seed in
the first round
what a ball game you talk about being
connected defensively look at how Miami
was
scrambling around this last play Vincent
with the active hands
Highsmith challenging
and time runs out on Grayson Allen at
the Milwaukee Bucks the Miami Heat will
be seeing the Knicks in the second round
a bit of a microcosm
of what's happened offensively for
Milwaukee since the third quarter
another clunky possession and it leads
to no shot attempt
with a chance to tie It Or Win It
and man these Bucks fans are stunned
I'm stunned it is so quiet you can hear
a number one seed drop yes you can